bonjour je suis un acteur ayant une
grande renommée aujourd'hui on va vivre
une heure dans ma pauvre en cadence
diffusé welcome to the game bienvenue
dans le jeu c'est le [ __ ] de nom du
jeu aujourd'hui on va être dans la peau
d'un hacker c'est parti nous game j'ai
pas tout compris à jour je préfère le
dire je vais pas faire le mytho mais en
gros on va aller sur le type web le
début et c'est quoi c'est la partie
invisible du web là où il ya tous les
trucs ghetto que google etc ne référence
pas qu'il m'appelle adam ce qu'on
cherche c'est 8 clés cachées sur le dip
web on peut pas les trouver sur tous les
sites mais à quelques sites qui les ont
on doit explorer chaque page cliquez sur
les liens et découvrir des trucs une clé
cachée ressemble à ça on va donc devoir
trouver ces huit codes et les remet dans
l'ordre pour atteindre un site web hors
du commun
on est paré avec notre grande expérience
de la cup quand tu explores le diplôme
tu est exposée face aux hackers super
bas je vais les contre-attaqués compte
c'est compliqué o'keeffe ce à quoi faut
le redire diriger vers la sortie
voilà allez tu vas plus pour qui bon
alors on peut être sûr du prêt bientôt
comment on fait oh non ça va chier
voilà où attendait un truc que je vais
te dire je passais légende ou pas mais
il est dit que plus tu vas profondeur
indique web puis tu as de chances de se
faire kidnapper par des mecs qui montre
localise je les attendrai avec mon gros
calibre je lèverai shot si tu penses que
80 de traquer juste éteint les lumières
de chez toi
abba d'accord ok si on se fait kidnapper
enfin ça allez c'est parti en vrille
dans le du poème jean-michel non mr
brock et même une page d'accueil
donc ça c'est la liste des sites dans le
dip web va devoir trouver les cotes sur
ces sites premiers sites dans le dip web
and auster qu'est ce que c'est que ça
d'accord ils marchent pas un oil est
d'accord tshosane wake ah ok alors
[ __ ] de recrues des codes l'adoma
question n'y a pas un code sur ce site
un code caché non il ya que des formes
bizarres de trucs improbables illuminati
ya rien viajes wah wah wah trois podiums
mondiaux maire du bugue bordel ok alors
il va soir à l'année vers le chemin
bonsoir des sorties ou tu veux nous
hacker ftp double a annoncé chantal
lignes de code c du rdpc aps longueur de
2 pc aps ringer et c'est quoi ce signe
bizarre auquel j'ai fait c'est bon ok ça
s'est fait un peu demandait pas qu'elle
ma technique
oh bah ça va des armes alors que
peut-être qu'il ya un truc cachés ici
qu'est ce qu'on prend on prend neuf
minutes mais toi un petit calibre 45 là
c'est à voir ça
ok ok ok rien ne nous échappera au nom
mais pas que le code va être cachés dans
tout ça mais non vous êtes sérieux et
mais jb g w o
on l'a on là il est là non non non
vainqueur de trois étapes [ __ ]
ok ok alors où la 1e c'est 5 à mon gars
que ces cinq à hyères tango dian qu'est
ce qui se passe ça va c'est qu'on ait
une team extrêmement entraîné d'anciens
militaires super de même qu'ils ont
kidnappés dans une heure c'est ça il
faut donner 25 mille dollars
ensuite ils font jobs est ensuite faut
leur redonner 25000 dollars les
résultats des gens affreusement des cd
ou des montages photoshop extrêmement
bien réussi on sait pas trop non non
allez allez allez ce bunker c'est quoi
ça là c'est sûr y'a un code il ya un
code qu'il parte faut chercher pour
chercher hier bruit j'ai eu un bruit gt1
lumière jetta lumière directe quoi ce
délire
yolain pas violent pas dans la maison je
suis très fier c'est bon c'est bon les
personnes
on est bien on est bien allez on y
retourne tous les humains ne sont pas
égaux il y en a quelques-uns qui sont
est supérieur aux autres d'accord ça
marche vraiment génial ce site on veut
des codes pour avoir accès à ce qu'ils à
ce que adam appel à red room
qu'est ce que c'est la red room trop de
questions / réponses qu'elle continue
oui de postes ces derniers d'ici à 108
postes est recommandé de la weed
d'accord 10 dollars le gramme 4e il veut
un bruit énorme
[ __ ] 6b 5 3 f la regarder sur cette
page on peut cliquer ici
ici au ya un truc h et maquiller un truc
cachée y avait un bruit vient brouiller
[ __ ] tu attends attends je suis en
forme auront à coeur la tuque pourquoi
celui qu'on ne peut pas éteindre la
lumière de sa maison sans s'étendre son
pc c'est complètement con et on n'a pas
de temps à perdre façon personne la voix
qui la paient impôts bolos comme double
ou créés à quoi il ya un bruit mais qui
est un bruit un bruit un bruit ce train
de faire
alors je voulais qu'on s'est fait avoir
ils pensent nous avoir si facilement
c'est moi leur dire que non et calvin
kidnappe il faut que j'aille chez le
coiffeur nouvelle game
ok on va trouver ses codes mon pote
c'est reparti la juste que ça change pas
c'est moi qu'on bouge le jeu ok ça
changeait quoi qu'on bouge le jeu [ __ ]
tous les sites ont changé c'est plus
comme thaler je perds tous mes repères
je suis comme la fouine
je suis sans repères familiers dans le
shop aux mondiaux peut acheter de
l'héroïne la cocaïne du speed plein de
trucs cool pour faire des super vidéo
c'était là
de l'école georges c'est sur cette page
qu'on avait vu en cause mais ça change
f des 32 f des 32 c'est noté on l'a
suivant news youtube hers
oh mon dieu des photos youtube hernu
[ __ ] voilà qui est intéressant ça
marche pas on ne le mets qui fabrique
des poupées de domec heures en on sait
que l'eau qui fait des poupées jeux
créer des jouets qui sont en fait des
femmes esclaves
vous vous demandez comment non contactez
moi si vous en voulez une tape à un code
à la place les mecs qui a forcément un
truc à faire avec le avec le chosen
américain voilà c'est ça suivent ensuite
c'est quoi je trouve le bon sur lequel
appuyer en fait ok c'est bon oh non non
non non non je t'ai pas le moment ce
n'est pas le moment ok alors c'est quoi
l'hymne ô mes mecs sénégal ans est
accusé
mais que ça va nous amener où ça c'est
quoi ce délire là il ya une énigme sur
cette page trope [ __ ] le mec il n'a
pas fait de bruit monga déjà qu'est ce
qu'ils faisaient là le mec et chassard
au carnage dans mon jardin il a cru que
c'était pour un gros carnage et je m'en
bats les couilles je joue pour un truc
c'est résoudre l'énigme
le reste je m'en fous le reste je m'en
fous d'école arrêteront j'm'en fous à
l'énigme change à chaque fois [ __ ] je
menais ma ok nickel nickel oui
yes suivant c'est quoi oui au [ __ ]
c'est quoi ce bordel
oh mon dieu faut cliquer sur l'un d'eux
oh il ya tellement de possibilités à et
celui-là
on a eu une urne on a eu ni heurts aux
mondiaux si je la mets pitié c'est la
fin du jeu the deep wiki 2 encore plus
de sites web dans lesquels cherché
pendant des heures sans rien trouver
vous savez quoi c'est que jade est un
hacker c'est dommage parce que j'étais
hyper fort je sais et je vais devenir
maçon fabriquer des maisons dans
lesquelles je sais plus à l'abri mais on
met la risquer d'être kidnappé à tout
moment mais chercher des codes pendant
des heures sur des sites perdu ça va ça
va le schéma crise d'accor dans la
trentaine
comment les jeunes cherchent pas de
cette vidéo sur welcome to the game
bienvenue dans le jeu bethioua nous
avait dit bienvenue dans le méandre est
vrai qu'il nous dise tout de suite ne
jouais pas bien là le fond du jeu est
bien mais j'avoue tu passe des heures à
chercher des codes sur des sites web et
un moment tu es un peu saoulé après
derrière avec le mec qui vient équipe
qui n'a pas de foule à la pression pour
sortir de son pays
voilà ça c'est pas mal